hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to
remember the movie Jaws that scary film
that made everyone afraid to go back
into the water
it took the world by storm the spielberg
classic was about a giant killer shark
who roamed the seas killing people
swimmers were dropping like flies
but luckily roy schneider came in said
smile you son-of-a-bitch and blue the
monster to kingdom come
allowing our heroes to live happily ever
after i'm not dead
Oh until he made an unexplained comeback
in Jaws too funny hey I didn't know
sharks could put themselves back
together so Neely could the no matter
she neither is back to save the day he
fights the creature off and once again
blows into smithereens allowing once
again for our heroes to live happily
ever after
ok alright God that is until Jaws 3-d
where once again the shark can't take a
hint that we don't want to see him
anymore ok you know the truth shark
screaming blow up zero regrets granting
filming privileges and once again our
heroes live happily ever after
hi Pierre oh happy Christ another one
shirk has more life than a soap opera
lead
that's right folks chose four is the
unnecessary sequel to the unnecessary
sequel of the unnecessary sequel it is
all the crap and over-the-top shark
attacks you'd expect to see at this
point and all you had to sacrifice with
your ability to give a shit it's the
very last in a very long line of
disappointment so let's head back into
the water for the worst of the worst
this is jaws 4 see that God how many
times are we gonna see that shark point
of view haven't we establish yet that
this is already the world's slowest
moving shark and on top of that the
movie is called jaws the revenge really
it's taken in four movies to finally get
a plan together it better be a damn good
scheme oh hey can I take a guess I'm
gonna say it's um sneaking up on people
and eating them am i close
tell me I'm close we're going Tiffany my
Christmas tree okay but it's wrong when
this year we open up with the wife of
Martin Brody Ellen Brody I know you can
use the poem by yourself you're a big
girl I know you're five years old hiya
kiddo how you doing down there in the
sunshine yeah yeah yeah where's the
shark can you get to leave early cut my
desk is closer to the door okay I guess
the Sharks got a while so let's
introduce the appetizers this is Sean
Ellen's son this is Michael her other
son where's my Schneider you might ask
well he's right there yeah I guess they
figure if they hold on this picture for
a good five minutes
somehow that'll count as him making an
appearance that bad huh
actually they say that he died in
between films and I have to admit I
always find it weird when they kill off
characters in between movies when we
clearly know the actor is alive like
with Sean Connery in the last Indiana
Jones movie brutal couple years ha
Charlie first dad and Marcus oh really
he died in between films yeah well I
sure hope you kept that receipt for that
cup of everlasting live kind of false
advertising don't you think is an old
dock piling drifting in the chat
stuck on a channel marker though sean is
called out to get rid of an old dot pile
and of course to do this he has to go on
a boat okay how long until he gets it
all right all bets are off let's take a
look
answer is two minutes well done
everybody well done not quite dead Jenna
by the way don't you just love how
there's blood already in the water even
before he attacks maybe it's so
intimidating that people just start
bleeding before they even see it of
course the shark bites him again and
takes him under leaving Sean's mother to
deal with the bad news okay well
somebody tell max von sydow to take off
that wig this is a serious moment
so her other son Michael comes in to try
and comfort her but the pain is too
overbearing she's been out there hours
how's she doing no dancing our rainbow
singing show tunes how do you think
she's doing
see ya you're so grown up uncle Sean is
dead you know will he ever come back I
don't know if you can blow by shark
three times I'm sure uncle Sean has a
shot but Ellen is convinced this is not
just your everyday shark eating
incredibly large boat incident there
must be a connection there came to him
what it's waited all this time and it
came to him waited all this time
where was he throwing up on SNL cast
members for practice I want you to get
out of the water
what come on sit down will ya we'll get
there I don't want anyone in my family
anywhere near the water never again
never oh no where is this coming from
can't believe that voodoo sharks don't
commit murder they don't pick out a
person to heat up Sean it killed your
father dad died from a heart attack
he died from fear the fear that killed
him oh so it's the fear of the shark
that killed him hmm that's interesting
considering how he kicked this thing
swam around it and blew it up twice in
two movies I'm sorry but that's really
insulting to his character people this
guy he had more balls than any of us put
together he is fighting a shark and
you're actually gonna say that he died
of fear well that's what he'll the
delayed response isn't it I mean what
was he just sitting around one day
saying holy smokes that was dangerous oh
so they go to Sean's funeral and in a
sort of bizarre scene she starts
laughing I guess she's thinking of all
the good times they had but look at
everybody they're looking at her like
she's totally not sometime and a time to
die I'm sorry I just saw dick in a box
for the first time
so Michael offers his mother to live
with him down in the Bahamas hoping that
being surrounded by even more water will
somehow cheer everything right
lady you got the reactions backwards
you're supposed to cry at the funeral
and laugh when you're with the little
girl they're gonna teach you anything in
acting 101 so they float down to the
Bahamas with the help of their pilot
friend played by Mudd go guy who you may
remember acting alongside much more
believable animatronics in the Muppet
Christmas Carol he actually starts to
befriend her and they have a little bit
of a romance going on meanwhile Bo
Michael has the incredibly exciting job
of watching underwater snails you go
away you leave me high and dry you want
to work by myself you come back acting
like a zombie it's Christmas Eve for
working all the time because of yo hey
I'm sorry about your brother what is
with the emotional transitions in this
movie they're all so sporadic is the
eastern seaboard just filled with
bipolars no they try to attach their
emotional awkwardness and still try to
have a Merry Christmas
sharp pure Jake hey may your sex might
be as busy as your shirt thank you mommy
what sex and keep our tea cups and
saucers and our sugar bowl and creamer
yeah it'll improve my sex life Oh what
but sure enough even in the Bahamas
Ellen Sharkey senses tingling
yes you're seeing this right people the
shark actually followed them all the way
from the United States to the Bahamas
holy shit how is that possible how can
you find these people you see like some
sort of technologically advanced super
shark huh
you won't get away that easily you text
the ship and only enough the cruise-less
terrified and more annoying oh that is
so annoying we should report him so
rather than saying holy shit sharks can
travel miles and miles solely fueled by
grudge Michael decides he wants to study
the creature now we're gonna do some
real research boy give me a favor will
you don't don't say anything about this
to my mom she would totally ground me I
mean last time I went out with a shark I
came back after my curfew I was in so
much trouble so of course like a dumbass
he continues to go out into the ocean
trying to tempt the shark
boy jaws is revenge plot doesn't have
much focus does it I'll travel miles and
miles across the sea just to get my
revenge uh-oh Kelly no no no no boy you
guys don't go around for the cheap stuff
do you clock whole damn it
eyes on the prize J boy eyes on the
prize so to be honest most of the movie
is just Kane and mrs. Brodie getting to
know each other better
well once in a while they'll cut to a
shot of the shark that's it yeah it's
like terms of endearment if it was
interrupted by oh I don't know a jaws
movie but over time jaws Maja's to get
the dart off I guess he had one of his
undersea friends with opposable thumbs
helped them out so of course they'd have
a hard time looking but don't worry he
finds them pretty easy
oh my God look at this the roof is gone
he's completely in the open and yet Josh
continues to eat the metal on the ship
you know for a movie called The Revenge
the actual revenge is extremely clumsy
you just eat him this is what you do
this revenge I only have two steps bingo
but thank God just like in every jaws
movie there's a sunken ship just a few
meters away you know he doesn't look as
scary when he's just wiggling his way
through tiny halls
you ever see a really fat person tried
to get through a tiny door kind of a
same reaction gonna be the day
your mother 54 turning Keys got another
speeding my easy morning fuck truck get
try this get that what soon so same time
tomorrow actually that's exactly what
happens it goes back into the water to
fight this thing but this time Jaws
isn't looking for ya
his ingenious revenge has now directed
him to a beach a couple miles away yeah
that's right the guy is literally
throwing himself at him and he's off at
a beach trying to eat some chance I'm
sorry I really don't get Jaws his plan I
mean again here he is out in the open
and you're eating this banana boat I
mean okay I guess you can make the
argument if he was going for the
granddaughter but she's right there he
literally ignores her and goes for this
other chick what does she have to do
with your plan what did she kick you
when you're all gun or something I'm
sorry I know I'm dwelling on this but I
won't concentrate on this aspect of the
revenge if the movie wasn't called by
revenge the fact that he traveled so far
to pull it off I mean if it wasn't the
revenge plot he was thinking of all that
time well then what was he thinking of
swimming to the Bahamas cross this guy
double rainbow cross the sky but this
time Ellen decides the shark is going to
fall it's time for jaws to face his
greatest opponent yet an aging wrinkly
old blond hair woman at this time it's
Posterous but everyone else decides hey
that's a fucking weak climax so the get
Michael came to fly them out to where
she's headed it'll find her what do you
know about it when she put the idea in
her head to date shark the Kilmartin et
on is following the family yeah that's
what I sake
what are you doing you're not flying
people
I deliver laundry
purely weird line but it seems like jaws
is getting closer and closer to his
target and the clock is ticking
it's okay sharks are terrified of
aviation everybody knows this till they
land the plane in the water which means
now jaws has four people he can munch on
for some reason he doesn't go after the
people already in the water and decides
instead he's in the mood for British
okay this movie might be worth it just
for that one line I wish I could be so
nonchalant about a great white coming
after me winning
oh yeah good thing in aging Michael king
can outswim a giant killer shark without
losing any of its limbs and coming out
the water almost completely dry
yeah look what we you just said earlier
yeah I shit but it turns out Jake might
have an idea about how to fix the
problem this is all theory though yes it
responds to external electrical info it
might be funny one coming from a fighter
according to the life force scan Eliezer
these rampaging creatures are from
Dimension X 3 get in town this we got a
clean shot the hell out right sunlight
could reverse a freezing process but
it's morning in the Congo I reckon the
receiver if it works if you get it
inside that Backman too then my
positronic sub-process detected high
frequency and her phasing signatures
from the organisms the short version is
a blinking light we'll make it man so
that's what they try
I do my impression of the dolphin
humping a God for you
well because it works so well the first
time they're gonna try blinking the
light on him again
huh can I think just roar oh my god
that's Josh roaring people I wouldn't
mind so much except I think I know where
this war came from this is the roar
Jerry let out in a Tom and Jerry cartoon
seriously listen gee if you're gonna
steal cartoon sound effects there's a
great boat little more you can rip from
so Ellen in a fit of rage starts driving
the boat towards the shark not exactly
sure what that's gonna do but let's find
out why are you stuck
hell he just blew up how the hell did
the shark just blow up okay all right
the other movies got bad but they at
least had a reason why the shark blew up
he didn't just spontaneously combust I
mean Jesus why are we so afraid of this
thing if you can blow up so easily
it's like the world's most sensitive
shark and get ready for dumb luck number
two the black guy survives yeah
look at him talking to everything you
know what I bet he actually feels better
I bet he actually feels better after
getting eaten by that shark the hell are
you doing alive huh I tell you another
tip equipment don't crap button well I
have no idea what you just said so we'll
just say a wizard did it and that's it
that really is it I don't know what
makes the death of this shark more
permanent than the other three but it
looks like this is finally the last jaws
movie
thank god this is not only stupid but
it's mostly kind of a bore the setup is
crazy the characters are not interesting
and it mostly feels padded out the
Sharks not as Vegas the third film but
it's still pretty damn fake and for a
film called The Revenge it's a pretty
lame revenge trust me when I say it's
safe to go back in the water because
anything is better than sitting in your
living room and watching vespi sighs
shit I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I
deliver laundry
you